MALE SPEAKER: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to another Authors
at Google Talk.
We're have to have DC
Pierson with us.
First time I met him, he was
doing improv at the Upright
Citizens Brigade theater.
And then I found out he had a
host of other things that he
did, which is write books.
He wrote and starred in a
independent movie that he did
as part of his comedy troupe.
And so we're very excited
to have him today.
DC Pierson.
DC PIERSON: Hey, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
DC PIERSON: Hey.
How's it going?
Thanks for coming out.
So my name is DC Pierson.
I wrote a book called "The Boy
Who Couldn't Sleep and Never
Had To." And then actually next
Thursday, March 7, my new
book is coming out.
It's called "Crap Kingdom," and
I wanted to talk a little
bit about that, and a little bit
about the process of being
a writer while also doing a
bunch of other things and
hopefully be funny and
or interesting.
I'd rather be funny
than informative.
Hopefully I'll be one or
the other, though.
So my book "Crap Kingdom" is a
young adult comedic fantasy
adventure about a kid who loves
Chronicles of Narnia, he
loves Harry Potter, he loves
basically anything where
there's a kid in the normal
world and he gets taken to a
crazy magical fantasy realm
where he gets told, you're the
chosen one, in this crazy
magical fantasy realm.
And then that actually happens
to our main character.
He gets taken to a crazy magical
fantasy realm from our
world, where he's told,
you're the chosen one.
It just turns out that the crazy
magical fantasy realm in
which he's the chosen one is
really, really crappy.
And so it's kind of a book,
among other things, about
trying to exist in two worlds.
Because he kind of likes
his life on Earth.
He thinks it's OK.
He thinks it's maybe too OK, and
the fact that it's so OK
means that he'll never be taken
to another world and
told he's the chosen one.
And when that actually happens
to him, and the world in which
he's the chosen one is really
crappy, he's like, maybe I
don't want to do this.
Maybe I just want to go back
to the real world.
Maybe I wasn't fully
appreciating it or whatever.
And that's kind of a little
bit what I wanted to talk
about in my own life, and kind
of my own journey, if you want
to pretentiously call it that,
with trying to exist in
multiple worlds.
So part of the premise of my
book, and I think also part of
the premise of most fantasy
literature--
I don't know if there's any
people who have been or are
fans of fantasy literature
in here.
I figured it was a
pretty safe bet.
But it feels like in fantasy
literature--
like things in science fiction
or things in real life, they
take place in a universe.
And universes are bound by
physical laws and science, and
they have actual boundaries.
And if you're an avid "Radio
Lab" listener the way I am,
apparently there's multiple
universes, and they're
expanding like soap bubbles
or something.
I don't really remember.
I just thought it was very
interesting while I was
folding laundry and I was like,
hmm, this really changes
everything.
And it did, but I don't remember
anything about it.
But in fantasy literature, it's
almost like instead of
universes, we have worlds.
We have that thing that's in the
front of the book that's
like the map.
It's like Middle Earth or
Narnia or whatever.
And worlds seem to be, instead
of like universes being bound
by like actual hard physical
science, worlds kind of seem
to be held together
more by vibe.
Like when you go to Middle
Earth, you know you're in
Middle Earth.
When you go to Narnia, you know
you're in Narnia, because
everything represents things
from the Bible.
That's what I love about
fantasy literature--
is that instead of these very
sort of hard, bound by
physics, soap bubble universes
that are constantly expanding,
you have worlds that are
connected by a wardrobe, or a
portal, or in my case in "Crap
Kingdom," a Goodwill donation
box in the parking
lot of a Kmart.
That should've been his
first clue, actually.
And I like, and have liked for
many years, as a person and as
an artist, enjoyed existing in
a lot of different worlds.
Because in addition to
being an author, an
actor, I'm a comedian--
I started in sketch and then
studied improv and now I do
stand up as well.
I'm in commercials.
You may have seen me trying to
sell you Allstate Insurance,
which I'm sure is fine.
I have Geico.
But anyway, it's
not important.
Dennis Haysbert's so mad
at me right now.
So I've liked being the funny
comedian person in a room full
of other authors.
And I've liked being the
literary authorial person in a
room full of comedians.
I really enjoy it.
I like going between
different worlds.
I like trying to learn
everything about whatever
world I'm in and mastering
it and trying to fit in.
I also like just being like,
whatever, I'm just here for
the day, and screwing around,
the way I maybe
am doing right now.
And I love that.
And the sort of interesting
thing about trying to pursue
multiple tracks at the same
time, or trying to be like a
polymath, if you want
to put it that way--
I do, because it sounds
awesome--
is not everybody wants
you to do that.
I feel like for the most part,
what people want you to do is
go, I am this.
I am the best this
that there is.
But I've always kind of
preferred to be like, well,
I'm a lot of things.
And if you encounter me
first doing one thing,
hey, I also do this.
And I can do all that
stuff, so I like
to do all that stuff.
And it's been a little bit of
a struggle, but I have found
some synthesis with it in and
around my most recent book.
But I wanted really quickly
talk about kind of where I
came from, which is a sketch
comedy background.
I'm from Arizona originally,
but I went school at NYU,
where I studied writing
for television.
And once there, I sort of fell
in with-- that makes it sound
like a gang.
I fell in with some sketch
comedy bad boys.
Not really, at all.
But I started doing sketch
comedy, and that led me to the
Upright Citizens Brigade
theater, where I learned
sketch and improv and stuff.
I'm trying to think of the
best way to approach
talking about it.
So I was in a really large 15
person college sketch group.
And then a bunch of those people
graduated, and a couple
friends of mine and myself got
put in charge of our college
sketch group.
And those guys were myself,
Donald Glover, who you may
know, who's gone on to star in
"Community" and also raps
under the name Childish
Gambino.
There was one dude that just
got like 10 times more
interested, and I like that.
He was like, oh, really,
OK, cool.
Put down my yam that
I'm chewing on.
And another friend of mine named
Dominic Dierkes, and
then a film director named Dan
Eckman, and a producer named
Meggie McFadden.
First of all, myself, Dominic,
and Donald, we ended up
running this college
sketch group.
We would put up these monthly
sketch shows, where the idea
was hey, all these 10, 12 people
that are going to put
on this show, everybody's
going to write original
material, we're all going to
band together and put on a
show, like we're kids in an
after school special that are
trying to save the teen
center, right?
And the problem was that
everyone else in the group was
all doing different things.
They wanted to work
on their major.
They were like, I can't write a
sketch this month because I
have to go be in a production
of "Pippin" that takes place
in space, so I can't
write anything.
So the three of us
would end up all
writing material together.
And I just realized I have
no way of knowing when
I'm going over time.
So Mike, if you could you give
me a light when I'm like half
an hour in?
All right.
Cool.
And he's like, now.
It's now.
So we would end up writing a
bunch of material together,
and it turned out we all really
liked each other's
style, and liked each
other's vibe.
I feel like I can use that word,
because we're in Venice.
And so the three of us plus
Dan and Meggie ended up
forming another sketch group
unto ourselves, where instead
of performing stuff live--
because every time you do a
sketch live, you have to show
up at the bar or whatever, and
like place all the wigs and
prop guns under all
the chairs--
and we figured, let's just shoot
these sketches once, and
then they can just kind
of exist forever.
And this was around 2004.
And the most that we thought
could happened was, well,
we'll put them on our own
personal website.
We'll pay for hosting, and
there'll be a little QuickTime
that shows up.
It'll take 12 minutes
to download.
Someone can watch this three
minute penis joke, and then
move on, and then maybe we'll
get to be on "MadTV," which
was still a going concern
at the time.
And what ended up happening was
we shot a couple sketches,
and we didn't have the money to
buy a server to host all of
our three minute QuickTime
penis jokes.
And the sketch "Lazy Sunday"
had just premiered on
"Saturday Night Live."
And that was--
maybe it's not the actual true
story, maybe like the literal
founder of YouTube is here,
and he'll disagree.
He's probably not.
He's probably in space.
But that sort of rocketed
YouTube
to prominence, weirdly.
The first time I ever heard
about YouTube was in
connection with "Lazy Sunday,"
and this sketch that played on
"Saturday Night Live" had had a
huge afterlife on this thing
called YouTube.
So I was like, oh, that
sounds interesting.
So I went into my school's
computer lab.
I went onto YouTube.
And I was like, I'll just upload
these sketches that I
have in my email onto to this
thing called YouTube, and
we'll just see what happens.
Because we don't have the
money to put them online
ourselves, so this seems like
an easy enough workaround.
And the name of our group was
Derrick, and I ended up making
our user name on YouTube Derrick
Comedy, and that ended
up becoming the name
of our group.
Which is a little bit weird--
it's like having music in the
name of your brand.
You're like, oh, comedy!
It's a little bit obvious.
But at the time, there was so
little on YouTube that wasn't
just cats dancing.
It's still proportionally not
that much more than that.
But because I wanted to be
like this is comedy.
What you're watching is people
trying to be funny.
And even despite that, most of
our early videos, the first
comment on them would
always be-- fake!
This is fake.
It's like, yeah, it is fake.
We made it.
It's fake.
You're right.
You're correct.
You can't fool me.
It's like no, that's fine.
I hope you think it's fake.
If you think it's real,
that's a problem.
And so it ended up kind
of taking off.
We had one sketch called
"Bro Rape," very cool--
very cool thing to say in
a professional setting--
that ended up kind of getting a
really huge, I guess, viral
audience, if you want
to call it that.
And then from then on, a lot of
our sketches had a lot more
eyes on them.
And instead of paying ourselves
with money that
ended up coming in when YouTube
started doing revenue
sharing, or from touring or
merchandising, which were also
things that we did with our
somewhat little slice of
notoriety that we were carving
out, we decided to put all of
that money into an LLC and try
to save up to make something
larger with it, like an
independent movie or a TV show
or something like that.
And that seemed like a
really great idea.
And then I graduated from
college, and I didn't have any
money anymore.
And then it was kind of like,
wait, so are we sure about
this LLC thing?
Because I could kind of use,
like, rent and pizza.
But so being in that college
sketch group and then going on
to being in Derrick--
and we made a movie, I'll talk
about it in a second--
I sort of learned a couple
things that I'm still eating
off of to this day,
or thinking about.
And the first one was when I was
still in college, and my
friend Donald was still in
college or whatever.
He is now a very
famous rapper.
He was just nominated in the
same category as Jay-Z and
Kanye West at the MTV
VMAs last year.
At the time, he was just an RA
in his dorm who just made
beats and raps on the side.
And I sound like a dad
when I say that.
He made some beats
and some raps.
He turned the hip hop crank
and some raps came out.
It was great.
That's good.
Have an apple.
But we would often talk about
the idea that we wanted to--
like, our dream in life was to
be able to just make your
whole culture.
We liked the idea that us and
our friends would make enough
stuff that a person could
conceivably live culturally in
terms of listening to music,
reading, watching movies,
watching TV shows, off just
the stuff that we made.
And it's a super lofty goal,
but I still have that in my
mind as what I would like to do
more than anything-- is be
able to sustain someone, I don't
know for how long, but
through just what we do.
And I still have that in my
head, even though it's a
little bit ridiculous.
And the other thing that I
noticed, and I was just
thinking about this yesterday,
actually.
When I first got into that
sketch comedy group in
college, and there
were 15 of us.
We were all very excited.
We were going to save
the teen center.
We would always talk about oh,
we should do a radio show.
We should do puppets.
You know, I don't
know, whatever.
Just all these different
pursuits that we
really wanted to do.
And this was my freshman year,
and I'm like, well, we'll have
all this time this summer.
We would always talk
about this summer.
We're going to do
it this summer.
We have all this time.
And I'm sure you guys have
experienced the same thing,
when you're working on a project
and you're like, oh, I
had this other great idea
for this thing I
really want to do.
It's a comic strip about living
pastas or whatever.
And you're like, I'm going to do
that as soon as this thing
is done, and I just have this
huge vista of time.
Well, what ended up happening,
as I'm sure you've experienced
as well, is that vista of
totally unencumbered time
never actually came.
It would always be the next
thing that we had to do, that
we had to keep working on.
And that still is true for
me to this day, where I'm
convinced, OK, after I finish--
like my book comes
out next week on Thursday, and
I have this foolish thing in
my head, like after that
happens, then I'll just be
free to just learn the guitar.
Or whatever.
Not that.
And it never comes, that sort
of ethereal summer of
unlimited creativity where
you're going to get a shack
and put a drum in it.
Never actually happens.
But I like to think that if you
kind of live a full sort
of creative life, then you turn
around after a point and
you realize that you've been
doing all that stuff the
entire way along.
It just didn't feel like that
perfect creative time of just
letting your mind roam
free on a porch.
And the final thing that I
kind of learned-- not the
final thing in my presentation,
no-- but the
final thing that I learned from
doing sketch and doing
improv and doing all these
different things is--
well, I didn't learn it from
this, but the first time I
heard it was in a Lauryn
Hill song.
I don't know if you guys are
Lauryn Hill fans, but she had
a follow up single to her first
smash single, "Doo-Wop
(That Thing)," in which she said
everything is everything.
That's the hook of the song--
Right?
Yeah, it's good, right?
Yeah.
There's a cool video.
New York City's like a record.
It's great.
You can watch it on
Vevo after this.
Give her some ad money.
Who knows what she'll
spend it on?
She's going to be so
mad at me for that.
But I first heard that song,
and it's a good song, but I
was like, that's such a silly,
meaningless thing.
Everything is everything.
That's such a silly sort of like
weird fake zen BS thing.
And what I realized through
doing sketch and doing improv
and then going out and trying
to do other things is that I
had already kind of in a weird
way learned not literally
everything I needed to know, but
a lot of what I needed to
know by learning how to do
sketch, learning how to do
improv, whatever.
Everything really
was everything.
I learned how to write like
children's TV and late night
jokes in college.
Because it wasn't
a real college.
And when I sat down to
write my first book--
this is what a book is--
I realized all of those skills
that I had learned trying to
write that "Law and Order:
Criminal Intent" spec scripts
were really helping
me write this big
work of literary fiction.
When we went to make our first
feature film, "Mystery Team"
the fact that we had been
studying how to write sketch
helped us know how to write a
movie in terms of what to do,
but also in terms of what not
to do, because a sketch is
different than a movie.
So the best thing I feel like
you can do if you want to
learn one thing is to learn
about anything,
because it all applies.
And that sounds very--
first of all, I'm certainly not
the first person to say
it, but it sounds very kind of
zen and hippie-ish and vibey.
But it really has been true.
It has proven true for me.
Everything really
is everything.
And I don't know.
Lauryn Hill is right
about everything.
Except for white people.
We're cool.
Let's see here.
I have a lot of cards that I
decided at a certain point to
stop flipping through.
Oh, yeah.
So I graduated from college.
And all throughout college, I
would go into the computer lab
really late at night, and rather
than working on the
work I was supposed to be
working on, I would just end
up writing short stories
or little
comedy pieces or whatever.
Because as I'm sure you well
know, the best time to get
anything done is to
have another thing
you're supposed to do.
And then you'll just be like
yeah, my living room is so
clean now or whatever.
And I would post them
on my website.
And I always felt a little bit
weird about telling comedy
friends of mine about them.
Because when you think of
comedians, you think they're
going to be like, hur, hur,
nice short story, dick.
Actually, I think I'm
thinking of Biff.
But people started finding my
website, and friends of mine.
And then one day I was on the
subway, and I was coming in
from Queens, and I saw
my friend Eliza.
And she was like, I really like
these short stories you
write on your website.
I was like, oh, thank you.
She was like, you should
write a novel.
And I was like, oh,
I would really
like to do that someday.
That would be something
I would like
to do at some point.
And she got really serious.
And it wasn't actually
happening, because it couldn't
really happen on the subway.
There are no windows.
But in my memory, the wind
started blowing through her
hair-- you know what I mean?
And she was like, a lot of
people say that, but not a lot
of people ever do it.
And then again, in my memory,
she then blew away in the wind
like sand, but she actually
just got off at a stop.
But that was the effect that it
had on me, was of somebody
who would then disappear
or whatever.
And at the time, I was temping
in the accounting department
at barnesandnoble.com.
RIP.
No, that's Borders, sorry.
Barnes and Noble is
still going great.
Go to their website.
Anyway, you have to suck up to
booksellers, I guess, when
you're an author.
But so I was working in their
accounting department.
And I was like, I'm on the
wrong side of books.
I want to be writing
something bigger.
She was right.
A lot of people say it.
Not a lot of people
ever do it.
And as I've come to learn, my
great motivators are guilt and
fear and shame and competition,
not really like
inspiration and what they're
supposed to be, the higher
minded things.
It usually comes from somebody
being like, you can't do it.
And I'll be like, I'll
show you, dad.
So I told Eliza, I was
like, hey, I will--
I got so much louder.
Did you guys hear that?
Is that maybe because
I turned this way?
I don't know.
Yeah, you're right.
Fair enough.
So I told Eliza, I was
like, hey, I'm
going to write a book.
I think I'm going
to write a book.
But I need you to every time
you see me just like bug me
about it-- just be like,
where's the book?
Where is it?
Hand over the book.
You know what I mean?
And I sort of made her into
my own mob enforcer of
motivation.
And she did it.
Every time she saw me, she
was like, where is it?
Where's the book?
And I was like, I'm trying.
So I quit my temp job at
barnesandnoble.com, and I
didn't have any money.
And then I booked one little
tiny web commercial that
allowed me to then have
like a month off
just strictly to write.
And then that sort of
kept happening.
Because I had been an
improviser, and I worked at
the Upright Citizens Brigade,
I had ended up getting a
commercial agent, because
I bartended there.
And then the fact that I had a
commercial agent meant I kept
going out for commercials, and I
would book just one thing at
the totally right interval to
not be entirely broke, and I
could actually write.
I could do it for my
job, basically,
and work for myself.
And I would not have been able
to do that otherwise.
So I finished the book, and
I sent it to my agent.
I didn't have a literary agent,
like somebody who could
go and sell a book.
I sent it to my acting agent
that I had gotten because me
and my friends made
popular dick joke
videos on the internet.
And she read the manuscript,
and she was like,
I really like this.
I have a friend who's
a literary agent.
I'll send it to him, and we'll
see what he thinks.
So she sent it to him.
He called me.
He was like, I really
like this book.
I want to represent it.
He sent it out to like nine
different publishing houses.
Eight of them said no, and
one of them said yes.
And I took the train in-- the
same train I'd met Eliza on--
to go and meet my editor.
And I was like, man, when I walk
through those doors, I'm
not going to be dick
joke college
sketch group DC Pierson.
I'm going to be like august
literary specimen, future
Pulitzer Prize winner, "New York
Times" weekend magazine
interview having, literary
DC Pierson.
And I walked through the
doors, and I go up,
and I meet my editor.
He's a guy named Jerry Howard.
He's been around forever.
He's super kind of tweedy and
literary and old school.
He's a person who you feel like
they're on Cape Cod even
when they're not, they're
right there in front
of you in New York.
He did David Foster Wallace's
first book.
He edited Bret Easton
Ellis's first book.
And so I was like, this is
just going to be such a
literary guy.
I'm going to have to
speak in footnotes.
But that's cool, I'm prepared.
And so I went up there.
And he turns to me.
Basically, the first thing he
says when he gets into the
room is, oh, hey, I just googled
Derrick and I love it.
It's hilarious.
That one video with the
dick, oh my God.
And what I came to find out was
that instead of keeping
these worlds entirely segregated
like I had hoped
to-- so I could be like, I'll be
a dick joke guy over here,
and then I'll be an august
literary persona over here--
that the book people, with their
tweed patches on their
jackets, who still do a lot of
graphic design work on floppy
disks, I swear to God, they
loved the dick joke videos.
They loved them.
They thought it was great.
It was a different thing than
what they were used to, which
is people that have like a
couple things published in the
"Utne Reader," and then they're
like, now here's a
novel about a novelist.
Not that there's anything
wrong with those.
And that was cool.
They seemed to kind of get it.
And like a year after I sold
them the book but a couple
years before it came out--
because that's how long
traditional publishing takes--
I had a meeting with Jerry, my
editor, and a couple of other
publicity people about the book
coming out, and what I
was supposed to do and
everything like that.
They were talking about all the
promotional efforts they
were going to do.
And I was like, so, is there
anything that I can do between
now and the book coming out,
Jerry, to help the book sell,
to help its profile?
And he just looked at me-- like
this tweedy Bret Easton
Ellis David Foster Wallace
dude-- and he was just like,
just get famous.
And I was like, does
it matter for what?
And he was like, not at all.
He was telling me I could be
early Lindsay Lohan if I
wanted to and get famous for
being good at acting, or I
could be late period Lindsay
Lohan and get famous for
crashing a vodka truck into
another vodka truck.
And I was like, OK,
cool, I'll do it.
I'll try to get famous.
So right around that time, my
friends and I in Derrick had
shot our first movie, "Mystery
Team," which we financed
through all that money that
we put into the LLC and I
therefore didn't get to spend
on rent and pizza, and also
some friends and family money
that they are slowly, slowly,
slowly getting back.
And we made our first feature
film, "Myster Team." And it
went to Sundance.
And it was an interesting time,
because it was the just
perfect, perfect asshole
of the recession.
Just right in there.
Again, a really fun thing
to say in a workplace.
And nobody was buying movies.
And our movie in particular
was sort of a hard sell
because instead of, again, a
movie about a filmmaker or
whatever people buy at Sundance,
our movie was about
three sort of Encyclopedia Brown
style G rated aw shucks
detective kids having to solve
an R rated adult murder, and
then being sucked into a world
of crime and drugs
and boobs and stuff.
And so the movie didn't
sell at Sundance.
And people would continually
ask us about the movie when
sort of trying to tell us why
they weren't going to buy it
and release it on 50,000 screens
was, well, why is it
the G rated characters
in the R rated world?
If it were just a G rated
thing, then that we get.
That's a G rated movie.
And if it were just an R rated
thing, that we understand,
because then it's R rated.
But the G to the--
And we were like, well,
that's the whole
premise of the movie.
That's what's funny
about it to us.
That's the whole idea.
It would be like if somebody was
like, OK, so "Star Wars."
We get Luke on the planet
at the beginning
on this home world.
We get that, that totally
makes sense.
And then we get the
stuff in space.
But why in the same movie?
It's like, because
that's the movie.
That's "Star Wars." That's the
whole premise, being on this
one world, and then going off
and having an adventure.
That's the whole what
makes it, it.
And they were like, hmm, bye.
And they pulled away.
And so the movie did end
up selling, finally.
We took it out here to LA and
back and forth to New York,
and it ended up getting
distributed.
And we, in conjunction with
our distributor, kind of
developed this very
unconventional plan.
And when people have money
and they hear the word
unconventional, they start
to get really gun shy.
And there's a reason they do.
It's because mostly conventions
are conventions
for a reason, because
they work.
We were doing something
unconventional, and it had
mixed results.
We toured with our movie
in all these
different college towns.
Because we're popular
in colleges.
We make dick joke videos.
People will love us
in college towns.
We'll just put ourselves out
there, and then people will
come in droves.
Dick jokes!
That's what they'll chant.
And so we went to towns like
Iowa City, Iowa, Ames,
Tallahassee, Gainesville,
Florida.
And all throughout that entire
time, what we ended up
experiencing was very, very,
very empty auditoriums for the
most part, but there would be
like three die hard kids in
the front row that were so
excited to be there.
And then we would do a Q&A after
the movie, and then we
would sign posters.
And I swear to God, in one of
the first towns that we were
in in Florida, the first kid
that came up to the table to
get his poster signed
was like, what are
you guys doing here?
Not in a way of, like, sweet,
but in a way of,
like, are you OK?
What has happened that you are
in Gainesville at this AMC
multiplex where all the
other movies have
$100 million budgets?
And the answer was,
we don't know.
We don't know what
we're doing here.
But aren't you happy
we're here?
And he was like, it's more
disconcerting than anything.
And no one knew we
were out there.
It would be a little bit
different now, I feel like,
because Twitter is a little more
prominent or whatever,
there is a little more of a
precedent of like, I'm in your
town, show up.
But maybe not.
It might have just been
the same thing.
So we kind of had to just get
our Henry Rollins on and just
kind of make it happen
somehow.
So the fifth town that we went
to was a place called
Columbia, Missouri, which is
an awesome college town.
I highly recommend it if you
guys are thinking of going
back to undergrad, journalism
school, or whatever.
And we were there, and it
was the same thing.
We were playing to like
three kids that were
like, why are you here?
Your parents are worried
about you.
And I was like, we've
got to do something.
So I had been going to Targets
and stuff before doing Q&As,
because I was like, there's
three kids here.
We've got to give them something
for being the only
ones that are remotely active
enough to find out
that we're even here.
So I would get them like
toy dinosaurs and weird
foam bats and stuff.
And then we were in Columbia,
and things
were not going well.
And we were at Walmart.
Don't judge me.
It's the only store in
a lot of places.
And I was like, what
can we do?
What can we do?
And I just saw this bin
of foam swords.
I was like, swords.
It's got to be swords.
So what we started doing to try
to build an audience in
this town that we were going
to be in for a week and
playing in for a week is we
would tell the people that
came to the movie, hey, if you
come tomorrow, you're going to
join Sword Club.
And they were like,
what's Sword Club?
And I was like, we'll give you
a sword, and it'll be hand
numbered, unique to you,
with an inspirational
quote written on it.
And they were like,
all right, man.
And they showed up
the next day.
They usually brought friends.
Because it was like, why are you
going back to that movie?
He was like, Sword Club, man.
And then the friend
wants to go.
Before we went out on the road,
a friend of mine, this
guy named Todd Sklar, who's a
really cool filmmaker and a
guy that also founded a company
that tours with little
independent movies to colleges,
strictly because he
wanted to get his first movie
that he made seen, and there
was no other way to do, he was
like, your main competition
when you go into these college
towns, your main
competition is not--
it's not even football.
It's not them going to
see another movie.
Your main competition is people
staying in their house
and getting high and
eating doughnuts.
And he was right.
And the doughnuts
were winning.
So that was the impetus of Sword
Club, was to beat back
with foam swords
from Walmart--
again, that's the only place
that they sell these
particular swords, and they have
them in all Walmarts, and
they're great.
Great product.
We beat back the weed and the
doughnuts in Columbia.
People started coming.
By the end of the week, we were
playing to full houses.
Oh, the other thing that we
promised was that if you
joined Sword Club, we'll take
your name and email address,
and we'll put your name
on the DVD, like
on a special feature.
We have that on the "Mystery
Team" DVD--
all the names of people that
joined Sword Club.
It ended up being about
300, 400 kids.
And it was also a way to let
people know that the DVD was
coming out and buy it so you can
see your name on the DVD,
and the movie.
It's pretty good too.
It's no your name or anything,
but it's all right.
So we did that.
And that battle against weed and
doughnuts has continued to
be a battle for me, and I think
for a lot of artists.
And especially now,
where it's like
people have these computers.
They don't have to go out and
do anything in particular.
You're really having to present
a case as to why
whatever you have is better
than weed and doughnuts.
And I think back to when I first
started doing improv at
UCB in New York.
There's four people that founded
the UCB Theatre--
Amy Poehler, Matt Walsh, Matt
Besser, and Ian Roberts--
and they built the theater not
from being like super famous
people on television, but
really from being on the
street in New York and being
like, we are a thing.
Come look.
It's better than just being
wherever you are right now.
And my first year I started
doing stuff at the theater,
which was during the magical
summer when we thought we were
going to have all this time, I
was part of a thing called the
street ritual, which is what
they would do to promote their
annual event called the Del
Close Marathon, which is a 72
hour nonstop festival of long
form improvisation.
And what they would do is they
would have a trail of
improvisers--
which is like the least
sexy phrase ever--
going from a park in the East
Village all the way up to the
theater, which is on
26th Street and
8th Avenue in Chelsea.
And you would pick up different
improvisers along the way.
And you would get a suggestion
at the beginning of the route
from just a random passerby,
and then you would start
chanting it, and then
it would morph.
And as you picked
up more people,
this chant would morph.
At one point along the route,
it was just us, different
sections of the mob, chanting,
Bob Dylan, Jakob Dylan, Bob
Dylan, Jakob Dylan!
Obviously, the answer
is clear.
But so as we were doing this,
we go into Union Square.
It's a beautiful summer day.
There's a bunch of people
sitting out just sunning
themselves, and we're
passing by.
And the most that you get out
of most people in New
York is like, huh.
Anyway.
Or a stockbroker dude being
like, listen, who's
paying for all this?
Because that's what they want
to know-- like, what are you
doing, what's the angle?
Which happens a lot.
And as we're going along, I see
Matt Besser, one of the
founders of the theater, run
onto the lawn and start
throwing flyers at all these
people that are sunning
themselves.
And some people would look at
them and some people wouldn't,
and he'd just start screaming
at them--
don't just be curious!
Don't just be curious!
Which is, when you think about
it, one of the most important
tenets of, I guess, marketing,
creativity, anything, is
trying to get people to
not just be curious.
Because I know I do
this all day.
You get a link to something.
This is pretty cool.
Oh, Boing Boing.
Oh, it's a TomTom.
Anyway, I'll buy that later.
And then they never do.
And the biggest thing that you
have to conquer is the idea of
people strictly being curious,
which is what most people are
satisfied to do, to pick
something up and go, huh,
cool, anyway, and move on.
And that is still something that
I'm trying to conquer.
And with Sword Club, we
did it a little bit.
The movie never turned into like
a overnight theatrical
sensation, but it has since
picked up an afterlife on DVD.
It was on Netflix for a while.
Now it's on Hulu.
Maybe it wants to
be on YouTube?
Legally.
So I realized that this sort of
thing has an outer limit.
When I was in Phoenix, and we
were still doing Sword Club,
it had become this weird
ritual at this point.
We'd go to whatever Walmart
was in our town.
We would sit down
with the swords.
We would look up inspirational
quotes and be like, Elvis
said, and just do it like
a job at that point.
I ended up being in Arizona
all alone by myself doing
these Q&As, because that's
where I'm from, and I was
staying with my family.
And I was getting a burrito one
night, and I saw a tattoo
parlor across the road.
And I was like, that's
the next step--
Tattoo Club.
I was like, if people
come 10 times--
10 times--
I will get their name tattooed
somewhere on my body.
And so I announced
it that night.
And I was basically--
I don't know if you guys have
ever seen the documentary
"Hearts of Darkness" about
Francis Ford Coppola making
"Apocalypse Now?" You should
check it out if you haven't.
But that's where I was at--
like Francis Ford Coppola mid
shooting "Apocalypse Now." I'm
like, tattoos, that'll
make it happen.
That'll take us over the top.
And so I announced it.
And then I was like, no one's
going to do it, right?
Three kids.
Three kids went to the
movie 10 times.
And I was like, OK, cool, and
went back to LA and was like,
I have to get a tattoo now.
And I kept in touch with them,
and after about a year, I was
like, guys, I can't get it.
I can't do it.
I just can't.
I'll make it up to
you somehow.
And then they're thanked
in my new book.
I apologize to them in the
acknowledgements section--
Tattoo Club, by name--
and I plan to do it pretty much
with every book since,
because that's the only
permanent thing I have to
offer anyone.
Because nobody wants
to be on my thigh.
So--
AUDIENCE: You should do it.
DC PIERSON: [LAUGHING]
I can't.
I can't do it.
I have to do so many
nude scenes.
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DC PIERSON: Fair enough.
Totally.
You could say that
about anything.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DC PIERSON: Oooooooh!
For those of you watching at
home, that guy just said, a
lot of people say it, not a
lot of people ever do it.
Fair enough, sir.
I am, like I said, a stand-up
and an author and an actor.
And I started doing storytelling
stuff.
I do a storytelling show called
"DC Pierson is Bad at
Girls," about how bad
I am at girls.
I started rapping a little bit
on some of Donald's early
albums, because I'm a huge hip
hop fan, and it was something
that I'd always wanted to do.
And so I still get the
occasional Twitter at reply
from somebody being
like, you suck.
And a few people being
like, you're awesome.
But a lot of people being like,
why did you do that?
Um, serious.
And when it came time to sell
this new book, "Crap Kingdom,"
to people in general, I was
like, what do I do?
I don't have a lot of money
to hire a publicist.
I'm all these different
things.
How do I explain that to people,
and make it into
something that is appealing
to them,
instead of just confusing?
Because it seems like it could
be a lot of messages.
And what I realized about what
I wanted to do with this book
in terms of actually getting
people to buy it was all of
that stuff.
All of the stuff.
And I've been living my life for
the past almost 10 years
now with a bunch of different
irons in the fire, and going,
like, when one of these irons
gets hot enough, then I'll be
rich, and that'll finance doing
all these other things.
And it hasn't happened yet.
And what I realized is that
instead of kind of just going
like, OK, it's just going to
be one of these irons from
here on out--
I have these irons.
They've all been in the
fire for a long time.
They're pretty hot.
They really are.
They're all pretty hot.
And at this point, I'm
like, fuck the fire.
My irons are hot.
They're the fire now.
My irons are the fire.
And to that end, what I've been
doing to promote this
book, to get people to pre-order
it, among other
things, is if anybody pre-orders
my book before
March 7, which is this coming
Thursday, I've been writing
their names, their full names,
into custom rap songs that I
then perform and
put on YouTube.
I've done 100 so far.
I do 50 names per song.
And people seem to enjoy it.
And it is that thing of being,
like, don't just be curious.
It's that thing of fighting the
weed and the doughnuts,
and being like, wouldn't
you rather have
a custom rap instead?
And the book, coming out March
7, which is really good and
funny, and you'll like it.
And it's been going
pretty well.
I owe a lot of raps,
but they're coming.
I wrote the third one, finished
the third one yesterday.
And it's been great.
It's been really, really,
really, really cool.
A couple of the other things
that I'm doing in terms of my
various irons--
I had like 30 minutes of
stand-up up that I've
developed over the past couple
years, just to try to be a
stand-up and to try to get on
TV, try to get famous for
doing stand-up and whatever.
And this year, I auditioned
to try to get a special on
television.
Didn't happen.
And I was mad about it, because
I was like, this is
really good.
I worked really hard.
You know, how the yearbook staff
will do in high school,
when you're like, my name is
misspelled, and they're like,
yeah, but we work really hard!
But I was like, I did
work really hard.
I'm really proud of it.
I want to put it out there.
And I was like, oh, I have
this book coming out.
How do those two
things relate?
And I was like, oh, if enough
people pre-order the book,
I'll put the stand
up out there.
And that's what I'm
doing right now.
I'm having an offer where if 100
people pre-order the book,
I'll put that stand-up special
for free on YouTube.
And I'm about a quarter of
the way there, and I
announced it yesterday.
And again with the rap stuff,
there have been for every five
people that are like, you suck,
there's one guy that's
like, when are you going
to put out a mix tape?
And I wrote and recorded one
over the course of like two
years just completely as a
hobby, because I know there's
a lot of people that are like,
you suck, but there's one dude
that's being like, you're
all right, man.
And I was doing it
for that kid.
And I did it.
And I announced if 50 people
pre-order my book, I'll put
out my first mix tape, like that
one kid has been saying
he wanted all those years.
And they did.
It happened last week.
50 more people pre-ordered it.
They sent me their receipts to
crapkingdom@gmail.com, which
is where you send your receipt
if you want your name written
into a custom rap song.
And they did.
And I put the mix tape out.
And it's been getting
feedback.
And have a track on there
where I'm like,
please buy my book.
And when I put the stand-up out
there, it's going to come
with a little wrapper on it
that's me being-- not a rapper
like rapper, but a wrapper like
a little bumper at the
beginning-- it's like,
please buy my book.
I'm putting this out
there for free.
Or if you have already
bought it, thank you.
I did the same thing with
my storytelling show.
I taped it a couple weeks ago.
And next week, I'm going to
announce that if 100 people
pre-order my book, I'll
put it out there.
And it is kind of my little
homemade way of trying to
create the feeling that movies
or TV shows or celebrities can
create because they have money
and time, and they can be
everywhere.
I'm trying to, for those people
that have been checking
for me over the years-- that
one kid who's like, you're
pretty all right--
I'm trying to create that
feeling for him of, like,
here's all the stuff I've
been working on.
Here's all the irons
in the fire.
And then on March 7, they get
a book, and I think they're
going to like it.
And I didn't realize it
until I sat down to
prepare this today.
But it feels very appropriate
to me to kind of finally be
opening all of the portal doors
and letting all of the
gnomes and elves and dragons
from my various worlds that
I've been cultivating over the
years, let them pour out and
let them help me try to have
a lot of people read
and enjoy this book.
It feels appropriate, because
the book is about the problems
of living in two worlds, and
I've been living the problems
of living in a lot of different
worlds for many years.
And I like that I'm finally
bringing it all together.
Hopefully, I think it's
going pretty well.
I like that I'm bringing it all
together to actually sell
this book that is about
living in two worlds.
And sort of, I guess, in
summation, I realized in
preparing this speech
that I wouldn't--
because I've had to over the
years, or sometimes just in my
mind and sometimes out loud--
defend the idea that I need to
do all these things that I do,
when maybe I should
just do one and
wouldn't that be enough?
But everything is everything,
and I wouldn't be all of the
things that I am without-- or
I wouldn't be any of the
things that I am without being
all of the things that I am.
And lions are cool, and witches
are cool, but you
wouldn't get to see any of
them without a wardrobe.
And to paraphrase "Pulp
Fiction," I am trying real
hard to be the wardrobe.
Thanks,
guys, [APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: So I think DC
will take some questions--
DC PIERSON: Sweet.
MALE SPEAKER: --if
anybody has any.
I'm going to get a marker,
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: My question is,
obviously, you do occupy all
these different worlds that you
talked about, and you do
them all very well.
Have you ever ventured into sort
of your own crap kingdom?
Is there a world that you have
tried to sort of occupy, and
it didn't go great?
Because it seems like--
DC PIERSON: Well, I write
for award shows a lot.
AUDIENCE: What was that?
DC PIERSON: I write for
award shows a lot.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
DC PIERSON: For scratch,
for money.
No, but even that is kind of
fun, because I get a lot of
great stories out
of it and stuff.
I met Gary Busey once.
That was exciting.
No, I mean, I don't know.
I guess as far as the things
that I don't want to do, I
hesitate to write a lot of stuff
where I'm shitting on
things that other people do,
because I feel like there's
enough of that out there.
And I definitely know people
that are artists and do, on
their Twitter feeds, like, this
sucks, or this whatever.
I guess I do a little bit of
that, but it always feels like
a., just sort of on a practical
level, you could
potentially alienate people who
might later employ you, so
just from a coward's point of
view, I don't like to do that.
I try not to do that.
Sometimes I can't help it.
But then also, it seems like
really bad karmic strategy, in
terms of putting that out there,
and then if somebody
were to do that to me, I'd be
like, hey, man, come on.
I'm just trying to
make a thing.
But there haven't, thankfully,
been too many things that I
have gone full bore into that
I haven't liked or wanted to
stick around for.
I mean, certain relationships.
But yeah.
It's a great question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I have a friend
who loves that quote,
everything is everything,
and I never really
understood what she meant.
Because I was like, that
sounds repetitive.
DC PIERSON: Right.
AUDIENCE: So thank you
for clarifying that.
Actually, that makes a lot
of sense and totally
resonates with me.
And so in that vein, since
everything that you do
contributes to who you are as an
artist, when can we expect
to see those tattoos?
DC PIERSON: [LAUGHING]
Oh, nice!
OK, that guys just said henna.
Yeah, totally.
That's a really good question.
So what you're saying,
basically, is that if I were
to actually get the tattoos--
which are owed to Jeremy
Seeliger, Darryl Seeliger, and
Jason Artigas, whose names
are tattooed in here--
that that would enrich
my artistic process.
I don't know that it would.
And it just seemed like a lot
to explain to a girl on a
third date, hopefully?
Why do you have three
dudes' names?
However you dress them up--
you can put them in flames
coming out of a motorcycle
being driven by a dragon,
but they're still--
yeah, I don't know.
I don't think I can do it.
I think I'm going to have to
continue putting them in the
acknowledgements of
things, or working
their names into things.
And I think they're
cool with that.
We talk over email.
I think they're all
right with it.
I don't think any of them
are too mad at me.
One of the guys was like,
yeah, I get it.
It's cool.
He was like, I didn't expect
you to actually do it.
And then I was like,
maybe I will do it.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DC PIERSON: I got some good
orange water here.
AUDIENCE: So I was wondering,
do you see your lifestyle as
something that might be viable
for others in the future, like
a multi-talented individual
that doesn't have to be
monolithically Hollywood
centralized famous but can
still make a living off
of kind of more
democratized media?
DC PIERSON: That's
a great question.
I was just, again, thinking
about this last night, when I
was prepping.
Because the whole reason that I
have been doing all of this
pre-order campaign and
everything like that is
because I do want the book
to be a success.
I want it to really be a thing
where it's like, this is a
"New York Times" best
selling everything.
I do want that, in a very,
very I guess cynical--
or not cynical, but just very
singularly focused, Daniel Day
Lewis in "There Will Be Blood."
Not that I'll smash
somebody's head in over
it, but I do want it
to be a real success.
I do.
It's just that I don't know of
any other way to build that
except for using all of the
other stuff that I've done.
I don't think it would be
terribly effective to take out
a bank loan to buy $20,000 worth
of Facebook banners.
I do feel like the best way that
that sort of thing can
spread is somebody being
like, hey, look at
this, to their friend.
Hey, come check this thing out,
because they're given
away swords.
Sweet.
But I do think that that's
definitely a viable option,
and it's something that, as much
as I am still listening
to Jerry Howard in my head being
like, just get famous,
doesn't matter for what, no--
I mean, I'm in an Allstate
commercial, dude.
It doesn't matter for what.
It really doesn't.
I do think that-- let's say none
of that stuff happens.
Let's say that it sort of
comes out and it doesn't
immediately hit the top of the
charts, which is very unlikely
that it will, as much
stuff as I've tried.
It's just really, really, really
mysterious, and the
algorithm that they
use to compile it
is shrouded in mystery.
Although maybe it doesn't
have to be--
dcpierson@gmail.com.
Hit me up, Google employes.
But if it doesn't happen, I was
thinking about it, and I
was like, oh, this sort of
campaign architecture that
I've put in place in a very sort
of haphazard jury rigged
kind of way throughout trying to
put this pre-order campaign
together, it doesn't go away
once the book comes out.
If anything, it continues to
help me stay in touch with
those people.
And all I have in terms
of people that
go and by the book--
most people that go and buy the
book, when they email me
about it, they aren't buying it
just because they heard me
on a single podcast and they've
never heard of me before.
Although that's happening
in some cases.
Or they're seeing a single
tweet or whatever.
It's that they have seen a
tweet by somebody, maybe
somebody famous they follow, and
they remember me from when
they were watching Derrick
videos when they were in
college, like this point
like seven years ago.
And it's great.
It really is.
Every time I can get in front
of your face is awesome,
whether that's in the Allstate
commercial or whether that's
in a dick and fart video from
seven years ago or whatever,
it all sort of when you see that
next thing, where it's
like, oh, that guy again.
It all sort of builds to that.
And so I do think that--
let's say it isn't just a smash
out of the gate success.
I will get to continue to do
these kinds of things, for
their own sake.
And I wouldn't even be getting
to do the strategy that I'm
talking about, where I put out a
mix tape and a special and a
storytelling show and whatever,
if I hadn't been
doing those things over the
past five years just
for their own sake.
I guess the short
answer is yes.
MALE SPEAKER: We can take maybe
one more question if
anybody has a burning
question.
Otherwise--
DC PIERSON: Tempting fate.
MALE SPEAKER: Huh?
There might not be
another question.
MALE SPEAKER: [LAUGHING]
All right.
Thank you, DC Pierson,
for coming to see us.
[APPLAUSE]
DC PIERSON: Thanks, guys, Thank
you so much for coming.
I really appreciate it.
Sweet.
Y'all want some books?